I have a saying in airing these for
about two months now why because I can't
afford to rent yeah yeah yeah
um
it's funny I was talking
about this and someone was like it's
crazy because people used to rent
because they can't afford to buy a house
and now people like you are Airbnb
because they can't afford to rent
especially in big cities like New York
La San Fran all thoughts let's talk
about it more after my shower
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
first this idea
to
move into an Airbnb it was very
temporary it was very very temporary I
was only gonna do it for about a month
and I would go about my Merry way
however then I was like wait okay this
let's not do that then I was like okay
this is unique opportunity
for me
to just explore different areas of town
um the state of the country let me just
explore different homes different
Aesthetics different neighborhoods and
see where that tastes me
now here's the thing when I say
like yeah I'm in it every week because I
can't afford rent and everything some of
y'all May jump to Airbnb and do that
monthly cost and be like um actually
this is quite expensive too girl I don't
know what you're talking about
what I mean by that is
is moving especially to New York has a
lot of upfront costs
I think a good number to put in general
if you're moving to New York is ten
thousand dollars you need ten thousand
dollars to pay for your first and last
month's any Brokers fees any deposits
all those upfront costs
you can say
you want about ten thousand dollars
ready for just that move-in about a
solid amount of it may you may never see
it again for example the broker's fee I
was asked last time I was interested in
an apartment in New York to pay a fifty
four hundred dollar Brokers fee that I
would never see again it doesn't go
towards my rent it doesn't go towards
the deposit I don't get it at the end of
the lease or any point in between is
just I'm paying fifty four hundred
dollars to this person I've never met
for something that I don't even
understand
that is not okay with me
like Fifty four hundred dollars
okay well now I can pay the 5400 but now
I don't have
a nest egg for moving into this
apartment I very much followed the rule
of you should have six months of living
expenses in your savings account I very
much follow that and now I I can't have
that because of this broker street that
I know nothing about
okay so this is my outfit just a t-shirt
dress
just a t-shirt dress and yeah we are
going to go about our day
let's go so I'm gonna do some more
walking and talking
what was the last
thing I said
um
I'm headed down to the living room
okay so right now I'm getting set up for
just coding and getting some work done
currently what I've been working on I'm
actually part of a new project
I'm part of a new project and what I'll
be working on is building some cards for
the uh UI of one of the XFINITY apps
so it's setting up that includes make
sure I'm logged onto VPN looking at my
emails looking at my suck messages and
just getting reacquainted with what I
left yesterday on how I love yesterday
one thing about working on a big team or
on a team yeah I don't work on a big
team on a team with in a big company is
a lot of the tasks you work on are
relatively like Concord small there's no
small work lots of work is relatively
small because
for me when I was learning to code and
transitioning into boot camp and making
portfolio projects and everything I was
making full web apps you know what I
mean from beginning to the end just a
full product here there's a
tons of people
working on a single web app or a single
mobile app and so really each team works
on a single aspect of that or a single
part of the software development life
cycle and so when I say like yeah today
I'll be working on creating a card it's
literally this just rectangular item
that's going to be on one page of the
mobile app that I'm working on nothing
crazy like it was so funny when I
realized that teens for example if you
worked in Google or something like that
there's whole teams for creating the
like comment box within Google Drive and
when people talk about one of the best
benefits of working in Tech it's a lot
of times the hours you put in or the
hours you don't need to put in because
not everything is as big as uh it was
when you were learning I'm working in
Swift UI something that a tech I have
not worked in ever before this team and
so still love learning to be done so
let's see how let's see how it goes
don't say You Wanna Give me space
[Music]
day for me
thank you
[Music]